[Music]
today officially marks one month until
Avengers infinity war comes out and it
just so happens that today we received a
brand-new TV spot trailer with new
footage in it now normally these
trailers are just released on TV and not
on YouTube our liner anywhere but today
Marvel themselves actually released the
trailer in today's video we'll be
watching the trailer then going over the
new scenes clip by clip and before we
get started please be sure to subscribe
to my channel to stay up-to-date on
Avengers infinity war in time you will
know what it's like to lose read it run
from it
the end is near
we got one advantage we have a tannish
once
so that's what we use
I think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good Wow
David don't side for one lives
we fight for all of them
put that thing away now I don't want to
tell you again okay not too many new
scenes here but the first new scene that
we have is by far the coolest one we get
a glimpse of Tony Stark's new bleeding
edge nanotechnology Iron Man suit as I
mentioned in some of my previous videos
Iron Man's new suit is made out of
millions of nano machines this means
that the nano machines can turn into
whatever Tony thinks of whether that's
his Iron Man suit normal street clothes
camouflage or a separate suit away from
Tony altogether this suit isn't pieces
of iron combined right it's not a big
chunk of iron that Tony has to get into
it literally forms a round Tony's body
this enables the suit to morph into
whatever Tony thinks of such as the
wings that we see on the suit in the
Entertainment Weekly photo released this
also enables it to heal if it's damaged
this is definitely my favorite Ironman
suit and it's really awesome that we
were shown footage of it morphing around
Tony's body the next new thing we have
is barely a second long and it's of
Wanda aka The Scarlet Witch in Wakanda
now we can see in the background all the
fighting that's going on right now
between thanasis army and the wakandans
and the Avengers what Conda is widely
believed to have the sole stone which is
why thanassis army is attacking it but
if we look at Wanda she has a certain
facial expression that is actually kind
of hard to read we know that her
invision have a special relationship and
in all the trailers that we've seen in
the majority of the scenes except one
where Wanda is fighting Proxima midnight
vision and Wanda are always together I
think it's safe to assume that she's
probably looking back at vision and we
know vision is hurt when he comes into
Wakanda my guess is that she looks at
all the fighting that's going on turns
around looks at vision who has hurt
right now and just unleashes this huge
attack on Thanos his army looks like
we'll have to find out one month from
now to see what happens here the last
scene is of T'Challa aka the Black
Panther saying today we don't fight for
one life we fight for all of them
sighs for one night we fight for one of
them what this scene shows us is that
Black Panther is really an Avenger now
he lets the Avengers come to Wakanda and
he's even using his army to help fight
Thanos he even lets the Avengers who he
fought against in civil war come to
Wakanda such as Captain America Wanda
and Falcon this really just shows how
much an Avenger Black Panther is now and
the key role that he's going to play in
Avengers infinity war so what do you
guys think of the new scenes that we saw
in the new trailer today do you think
we'll get more of these new TV spot
trailers in the next month or do you
think Marvel will come out with more
themselves let me know in the comments
below and please be sure to give this
video a like and please subscribe to my
channel to stay up to date on Avengers
infinity war Marvel and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof